you know why we all make mistakes second
chance
I hope it's disgraced movie mogul Harvey
Weinstein half-asses his way through sex
addiction rehab more and more women
ranging from Oscar winner Lupita Nyong'o
to former teen star Molly Ringwald keep
coming forward with stories about his
abusive and sometimes criminal behavior
even his brother and longtime business
partner Bob Weinstein has disowned him
calling him indefensible crazy and
remorseless but the Weinstein story is
not just about the end of a career it's
about the end of an era
the Miramax co-founder is only the
latest in a long line of powerful older
men whose professional lives have ended
with revelations of long-term harassment
and worse Fox News cashiered its founder
Roger Ailes and star host Bill O'Reilly
because of similar charges and Bill
Cosby's 2014 comeback was destroyed
after claims surfaced that he drugged
and raped over a dozen women the head of
Amazon Studios was forced to resign last
week after he was accused of repeatedly
and insistently propositioning the
producer of the streaming services
acclaimed series the man in the high
castle Weinstein was widely and rightly
derided for blaming his decades-long
behavior on having come of age in the
1960s and 70s he said when all the rules
about behavior and workplaces were
different why don't you let me take you
about sex among other things such a
defense ignores the inconvenient fact
that the 70s ended nearly four decades
ago today on the press and on the radio
the American career girl married or
single is a favorite subject for
discussion but he is right that
workplace expectations have changed and
that's largely because the workplace
itself has changed about 60% of women
are in the workforce compared to just
43% in 1970 in fact more than half of
all management professional and related
positions are held by women the pay gap
is also essentially vanished a study of
33 countries including the United States
found that when comparing workers doing
the same job men may just 1 point 6
percent more than
as I travel the world and represent our
company I listen a lot with higher pay
positions and status comes more
workplace power my name is Victoria
Valentino and I met Bill Cosby in 1969 I
was a folk singer Emmylou after my son
died it was very difficult power that is
amplified by social media and other
technologies that empower dissent and
make it harder and harder to maintain a
sexist status quo she won the Heisman
Trophy with his DNA rape kit there's a
real issue that in the aftermath of the
Harvey Weinstein revelations behavior
that is merely boorish or one-time-only
will be conflated with systemic sexism
and far more reprehensible crimes but
surely it's more than coincidence that
the Weinstein scandal broke just after
Hugh Hefner the absolute personification
of old-school pre equality male sexual
identity was being lowered into the
ground the old days and the old ways are
being laid to rest and that's a very
good thing for all of us regardless of
gender
[Music]